you
well Don thanks for for joining us today
it's a great
have you out for your ms Rai
Distinguished Lecture which you just
gave and now in a small in a smaller
room by a fire here we can talk a little
bit more personally about about your
career and your current role what's your
current position and how do you describe
what you do daily at uber I'm leading
data science for maps so that's all of
your experience as a rider of the map
when you from the time when you open up
the app all the way to the time when you
get to your destination and get out of
the car similarly on the driver side
turn-by-turn navigation for drivers for
example so every aspect of the map
that's rider facing and the driver
facing is part of this mapping system
but then also some things that that may
not be as obvious so for example the
mapping system predicts the travel time
for drivers from point A to point B for
any a and B and that's used when we want
to when you request a ride is that as a
rider we look at the different cars that
are available and see how long would it
take that driver to reach you and so
predicting that travel time in the road
network is a really important output of
our mapping system that may not be as
visible it's really kind of cool just
now during the talk you just gave you
talked about how it's not just machine
learning it's not just prediction but
the job you're in right now I would say
at what are the most well-known and
premier companies trying to do its work
to master the shared economy comes at
the intersection of economics and
statistics and logistics optimization so
many different fields that can be
together for you yeah that's right it's
it's an exciting opportunity to use my
interest in statistics and machine
learning and optimization economics is a
new field for me in terms of economic
models they're important and in pricing
and so it's been really fun to learn
from some of the some of the top
economists in in the field who have
joined the team you came to to uber
after your trajectory of going from high
school to Stanford Chemical Engineering
you mentioned earlier it's a
it's a math degree math and CS and then
off to Duke to to do statistics then to
Cornell as a professor and then you
Microsoft Research visiting visiting us
and working with us some predictive
models for traffic among other things
too now in this incredible position
where you're bringing together many of
the pieces and experiences you've had
now as you as a professor given what
you've seemed going on in your daily
life the kind of job that you have at
uber and the people you work with what's
the future curriculum for for students
to be able to master this world so I
absolutely think that training students
in being data-driven and driving
decisions through insights from data is
a critical skill set the most critical
skill set that that I look for when I'm
making a higher so in addition to being
able to build a machine learning model
that's this individual needs to be able
to engage with data they need to love
data they need to to when they go to
make a decision their instinct should be
to look at the data first and understand
what's going well and what's going wrong
it's a difficult skill to teach but I
but I think more hands-on analysis which
is is neglected a bit in in courses even
these days because I think it takes more
time from the professors so lots of
hands-on data analysis data analysis
using some of these very large scale
industrial data sets that are now
available in the public sphere more
coding for you just when you improve
your talk you just gave to the larger
audience you mentioned and showed these
pieces coming together an interesting
novel ways the economics optimization
prediction is there a new kind of core
coursework that's needed it seems like
it goes on beyond data science it's now
this could be something about
that might resonate deeply with
companies like uber and other companies
coming to the fore that needs skills you
might say applied across disciplines
jointly at the same time to solve
problems right well it is important for
students to come in with a basic
foundation in these different areas my
undergraduate degree was great for this
because we learned some economics and
some optimization and some statistics
and some machine learning so I would say
that that's very important just a basic
understanding of these different areas
but we really don't expect anybody to be
coming in with being an expert in all
four or even two of those instead we
pull together teams who are people who
have a broad set of with a little bit of
understanding and then a lot of depth in
one area we create these diverse teams
with different specialties and then we
try to get them to talk to each other
and to talk a that the other person can
understand and to bounce ideas off of
each other and and this is how we get
the the best decisions at the end of the
day I know looking at at your previous
history and we've had attempted we've
chatted in the past about your career
and so on I'm just Chris how did you get
involved in in just doing a math major
math and CS at Stanford when you in high
school did you always know you liked
math I bet I'd always loved math
actually it was a internship at at
Rockwell scientific where I was doing
machine learning research in
undergraduate that got me inspired so
actually at the time I was a major in
chemical engineering and after the
internship I decided to switch to math
and Comp Sci as a focus and eventually
that took me to getting a PhD in
statistics and continuing in the field
and circling back into tech and data
science these days it all started back
in an internship with with what was a
defense contractor machine learning lab
for defense contracts this is Rockville
Science Center in Palo Alto that's right
that's right
place very well during my graduate work
at Stanford who'd you work with there um
mark Piatt Oh fabulous well he's um he's
a mutual friend and I worked closely
with him as well for a number of years
when I was at Stanford during graduate
school what did he do it around well
science center do you remember oh wow I
was creating systems for training and
inference and Bayesian networks that
could be used for it for a variety of
different purposes they had a lot of
different different contracts at the
time for different military applications
yeah it wasn't all military they had
they had the Space Shuttle they had a
bunch of other things
it was great they set up shop right in
her Stanford campus and a number of us
he stopped by there and get a taste of
this other world and there was a big
rise of interest in those days as I
recall in decision theory and decision
making under uncertainty that's great so
so that moved over to math and you
thought I saw some real-world aspects of
it and um and then we when you were
getting ready for grad school which is
making like so actually I had a decision
to make between going to graduate school
in statistics and doing it in computer
science I had done a couple internships
at that point when I was making the
decision a couple internship with Moises
Goldschmidt after the internship at
Rockwell scientific noise Moises was of
course a researcher at MSR in later
years but I in the end it was six and
one and a half dozen the other there's a
lot of great work going on in artificial
intelligence and machine learning at the
time and also I wanted to understand
some of the foundations of statistical
learning that had been developed over
the previous 150 years so I ultimately
decided to get a statistics PhD great
foundations yeah absolutely it's
important to understand that I think
sometimes in machine learning we
reinvent some of the concepts that were
learned early on but it's also true that
the machine learning field has done I
would say a much better job of being
ambitious in terms of its problem Joyce
I think statistics is a little bit more
conservative as a community and and
wants to really ground
the assumptions that statisticians are
making in their models and make sure
that they want to be really careful
about the assumptions
whereas machine learning researchers are
often more ambitious about the
difficulty and complexity of the
problems they tackle so we both have
this statistics community and the
machine learning community really have a
lot to teach each other
well they mean it comes down to choice
of problems aesthetics but it really is
all statistics ok no so
so this area that you're in now so you I
mean you you just want to jump into Ober
because I think it's a really
interesting topic area this this whole
idea of the the sharing economy and
scale and the ability to collect all
this data most hopefully which is
anonymize typically but still the
opportunity to do optimization and
prediction it's such an exciting world I
don't hear your centralized dropping
into the overworld from from your
University position right well the most
amazing thing what is being able to go
from an idea to deployment of that idea
in a couple of months and so getting
really fast feedback about how well an
idea works in practice at very large
scale of course in in academia you have
much more time to develop the algorithms
and to go very very in-depth on a
particular problem space but the
timescales for deployment and getting
feedback about how well your systems are
working are much longer so that was very
exciting for me coming into tech and and
of course since I'm leading a team
there's those individuals are working
across a variety of different spaces
within maps and and marketplace that at
uber and each of those individuals is
developing and deploying algorithms and
so just to see us move as a team so
quickly and and to learn from that and
to understand what types of algorithms
work well in particular situations is
really exciting it's expensive too
because as I mentioned in the talk
we pull algorithms from a variety of
different areas economic models
optimization model statistics and
machine learning and and for example if
you look at the the pricing space
there's literature on pricing both
coming from the optimization literature
and coming from the economic literature
and so we hired some economists and
hired some people from operations
research and we put them on the same
team and people were just coming up with
ideas and and and trying them and seeing
which worked what worked best of course
of course with safeguards in place I'm
really thinking about but how lucky is
to have someone like you you know cuz
I've I've looked at your work over the
years and it's like wow she's been
working on optimizing where ambulances
sit in a city to optimize to minimize
their time to transport potential
accidents to the right hospitals using
prediction times and urgencies of
various kinds you know kind of a
interesting important societal project
you wouldn't think it's like you know
mainstream it's early it's very
important and all of a sudden you're in
this new world you know you're doing
that work before you were even existed
right and here you are some was looking
you resume saying oh my god this is what
we need forever very something very
related so it's interesting it's
incredibly closely related these
challenges around in the ambulance
context of that problem a bit sure sure
so the one of the problems that I worked
on at Cornell was about optimization of
location and relocation for ambulance
algorithms so if you have ten ambulances
in a city at a given time where should
you locate them so that they can
maximize the probability of reaching a
potential emergency in time okay meaning
before the the person has severe
detrimental health impact so so there's
some sophisticated optimization
algorithms for ambulances for these
location problems and that requires
inputs which is the prediction of where
and when these emergencies are going to
take place and you can see the direct
parallels with the ride-sharing
ride-sharing context in which the you
have this these drivers and the road
network you have instances of demand
where riders want to be transported from
one location to another the ride hailing
context is more complicated than the
ambulance context not only because of
the scale and I think at one point I
calculated the difference in scale do 10
to the 4 factor injuries but but also
the fact that drivers of course have the
ability to decide where and when they
want to drive which is different from
the ambulance context in which we can
ask we we can tell that to the ambulance
drivers where to locate it's just thing
if I open up my uber app and I see a Red
Cross uber emergency I'll know where
that idea came from the future pity
about that so what what's the most
surprising thing that you've noted in
your your career uber let's come up
that's kind of you didn't expect or
interesting or surprising about the role
surprising that's interesting well I
when I came to Eber I didn't expect to
be leading a large team actually that
was a bit of a surprise and definitely a
change I I was planning on doing an
individual contributor role on the team
and I was talking to to Travis the CEO
at the time and it turned out that there
was a need for a broader management role
and he asked me and and if there's one
principle in my career its if somebody
asks you to do something that you think
is far beyond your capabilities say yes
anyway so so I just jumped in and and
learned as I went that's probably a
really good heuristic except if it gets
to administrative you want to say no
quickly and figure out what level you
want to be at an organization it's
interesting to think about this do you
see yourself staying in the in industry
for a while or heading back to
amia how's that how do you how will you
weigh that decision over time do you
think so I want to exact answer right
now but how will you look what process I
really love what I'm doing right now
I love the impact I love the the
immediacy of the impact I really enjoy
the teams that I'm working with and the
ability to hire this incredible talent
and economics and optimization and be
able to learn from these people I love
what I'm doing I don't have any plans to
go back to academia in the near future
maybe way down the line no this does
unfortunate Cornell students who won't
have you as their teacher and mentor
interesting
do you have reflections about your time
at Microsoft Research you were here for
for a year and then here before that as
well
well done some pretty wild things you
worked on on data center forecasting
forecasting crises and in data centers
you any reflections about that work
about the data center yeah interesting
yeah I would have loved to have seen how
well it worked in in practice I I I
think that this this area of analytics
for decisions backups what were you
doing oh sure sure so the the problem
there was if you have a distributed
large-scale distributed system a data
center and these these data centers are
instrumented we know for each of the
servers in the data center we have
information about a variety of metrics
like CPU usage and memory utilization
and so on and so you have a lot of data
coming out of the system and sometimes
the data centers don't hit their SLA
something goes wrong and you have to
figure out what happened and do
something about it very very quickly so
you have so you say you have these
performance crises and in the data
center and so diagnosing what went wrong
is an important challenge so this was an
automat we created an algorithm for
automatically detecting previous crises
that looked very similar to what's going
on right now and if you had gone back
and diagnosed exactly what the cause of
that previous crisis
was then you know what's going on right
now you can do that in a matter of
minutes and then decide what the
appropriate intervention is so it's
something that I wrestle with all the
time which is work-life balance given
how passionate yeah I tend to be about
everything going on and I want to get so
much done and this there's so many fun
and there's interesting projects I can
choose to go deep on just a few or one
or pop up and do a few things at once
but then there's family and kids
relationships what's your sense for me
how do you master work-life balance and
how was it for you these days that's a
fast-paced company like a movie right I
actually find that that downtime has
become more important in my current role
than it was in in my previous roles so
the experience of management is so much
around being in the right headspace when
you're interacting with that person so
much around inspiring people engaging
people helping people to thrive and so
the the time that I spend with with my
friends and with my family is incredibly
important to being in that right
headspace so actually I've I've moved to
a much more balanced approach since
since coming to burr and I think it's
really it's really benefited my
management but sounds like it's it's
it's very mindful as opposed to organic
you give them you actually have a plan
flip which to that I think that so what
you're saying you know be something I
need to take some advice from you about
this sometimes yeah right well it's so
important to be in a positive headspace
whenever we're having critical and
difficult conversations in some cases
right and so to - you have to build up
this reservoir of that positivity and
it's also is also interesting that in
other aspects of life I think I I learn
lessons and bring them back to my work
at one point I was I had a hobby I was
playing electric bass and I felt like
some of the things
that I learned I had no idea with that
Yui base my electric face I just love it
it sounds amazing and besides everybody
needs a bassist they don't necessarily
need everybody wants to play the guitar
everybody wants to play the drums not
that many people want to play the things
that mask music too and that was one of
my dreams is taking enough time to learn
the bass so it's good yeah so it but
there's a kind of there's things that I
learned from playing the bass and that I
that I've taken back I did briefly play
in a in a church band in North Carolina
yeah oh my god that sounds like like
serious bass duty there was a lesson
there that I learned around what's
called staying in the pocket okay and so
as a musician and playing the bass it's
really important to be consistent and to
be steady and to always be that person
that people can rely on you don't go and
play some crazy bass line in the middle
of a song that's not your job right so
that's called staying in the pocket and
that lesson is so important in life and
in work I think staying in the pocket so
so just being incredibly mindful of what
is my role in this particular
interaction and and not going outside of
that that's really interesting I'm
thinking about whether or not you were
the kind of person that tended to stay
in the pocket before you learned about
this metaphor or it's actually helped
you helped you to deal with with making
sure that you were a little bit more
gentle with people I think I'm not
naturally a person who who listens first
and and thinks carefully about that I
tend to get excited and want to get
engaged with it with a response but
really stepping back and understanding
what my role is in this situation that's
really important so let me ask you a
quick question giving what you've seen
it ooh BRR
the inside yeah it's the personal car
going to go away is the personal car
going to go away not in the immediate
future 15 20 years out 15 15 20 years
out I think that's that's definitely the
vision the I think it's and you already
start seeing this we're in the
high-density urban cores people are
deciding to rely heavily on a
combination of ride-hailing services the
bike share services and public transit
now that all these options are available
people are people in urban cores at
least are much more than previously
deciding not to buy that car and I think
we will see this evolution it's a slow
one because in order to in order to move
over to the world there's all these
corner cases that you have to solve for
for example you have to make sure that
one when you have a small child that
there is a transportation option that
involves a child seat so so in the right
handling services just haven't nailed
that particular aspect right so then
what you end up happening at least at
least what I imagine happens is it's
somebody even if they didn't decide to
have to own a car before when they have
a kid and they need the child seat then
they buy the car at that point right and
then you have the current once you have
the car then you're not utilizing the
right handling services that much so so
in order to really move into that world
we really have to provide services that
fill all of these people's needs all it
needs at all stages of life and and also
to really leverage these multimodal
transit combination in order to create a
really price effective solution we're
looking towards the combination not just
of vehicular transport motor vehicle
transport but also the combination with
bike sharing and with facilitating
connection to public transit and so on I
have to say that one of my long-term
predictions that I've that I've made
about the future of technology is that
within 20 years at least one major city
will close some significant part of
inner core to human driven vehicles
it'll just be all public micro transit
very high speed
you know coordinated transit that will
then become a demonstration for the rest
of the world so I just have that
reflection that I can see that coming
that's interesting but don't you think
it it will be a combination of companies
providing services and centralized
infrastructure I'm not sure it could be
one company or a city that does invests
in public micro transit I use that
phrase these these you know three Doors
special little pod vehicles that you
know come and go really quickly that are
interleaving no traffic lights because
they're all coordinated and an inner
city if you need to drive in as an as a
human being you'll get a permit and you
get a little special beacon on your car
and all the cars will part as you come
driving in and with your over here you
know you've been driven vehicle yeah but
we'll see how the future goes I mean did
you ever do any other kind of
predictions you might want to make about
that but but the shared economy and an
optimization logistics economics coming
together even beyond transportation
beyond transportation well I thought a
lot about the transportation space yeah
sure there's I think there's these
interacting revolutions going on in
transportation and one way of
summarizing this is the acronym Asus so
autumn automation like automated
vehicles connectivity so the vehicles
talking to each other and to the network
electrification and sharing and that
these the if you look at the efficiency
of ownership of a private car when
individuals own a private car on average
they're only using that car a couple
percentage of the time two three percent
of the time and so extremely inefficient
use of the vehicle and there's a lot of
resources that go into creating that
vehicle and if you look at utilization
of the roadway
is also quite low because the traffic
congestion patterns cause inefficiencies
like the waves and traffic caused
inefficiencies and so if you look at
these four revolutions in transportation
they really build on one another and
together could create a much more
efficient picture so for example the
connectivity could help with these waves
and traffic that you see if the cars are
both automated and connected then that
means that you could have the closer
spacing between the cars like you were
talking about and you could avoid these
waves in traffic the waves and traffic
are caused by human behavior so so you
seem like such an inspired person who
the mentions in your life who's inspired
you I would call it two particular
people one is that I mentioned before
there was moist house Goldschmidt has
helped me throughout my career so as a
professional mentor he's been incredibly
important I think I've counted up the
number of jobs that that that he's
gotten me at various times three I think
he's gotten me three different jobs and
six job absolutely but if we look on the
personal side I would say that my mom is
an incredible inspiration she was way
ahead of her time because she got her
PhD at Stanford in demography in the in
the late 1960s she was one of the few
women who was doing that at the time and
the attitudes towards towards women in
in academia were totally different at
that point so she was interested in
going into an academic career afterwards
she she asked the head of her department
was that when she was when she was
graduating she asked the head of our
department for a reference letter and
and she was pregnant at the time and he
refused because she was pregnant so it
just goes to show that the attitudes
really do to me
and and but she was she thrived
nonetheless when she loved to do so she
did a postdoc at the east-west Center in
Hawaii again studying demography she
later went on to lead the International
branch of the Census Bureau and the US
government for decade or more she was a
professor at Hong Kong University of
Science and Technology for a period of
time done incredible things throughout
her career very groundbreaking so she
was always a person that you couldn't
you couldn't tell her what she couldn't
do she was gonna go out and and previous
feel you've inherited some of that you
know type and you know ty probably yeah
well I I hope I hope well that's great
to hear but you your mom it's fabulous
that when you have a parent that's so
inspiring yeah this is great
well thanks so much for coming is
anticipation seeing you again it's great
to see you again